the gentlewoman from New York ms Ocasio
Cortez is recognized for five minutes
Thank You chairwoman waters and thank
you all for joining us here today I know
it's been a really long day the purpose
of this hearing is to review globally
systemic banks ten years after the 2008
financial crisis so just know that while
I'm tough it's not personal okay I was
really going back and reviewing these
last ten years and I have concerns about
how much things have really changed I
did an assessment and year by year let's
go back to 2013 2013 at Chase had to pay
out twenty seven hundred and twenty
million dollars in fines to the Fed
Effy's SEC and UK financial conduct
authority for failing to oversee its
trading practices including what is
known as the London whale 2014 Bank of
America agreed to a sixteen point five
billion dollar settlement to the DOJ and
others for misconduct related to
mortgage-backed securities and a twenty
million dollar penalty with another 727
million in consumer relief 2015 Bank of
New York Mellon 714 million to settle
claims that a defrauded customers when
it promised to exchanged at best rates
for customers but instead used the worst
rates and pocketed the difference 2016
Wells Fargo entered into consent orders
for fraudulently opening millions of
accounts in customers names without
their consent or knowledge 2017 State
Street seven months after installing the
fearless girl statue paid five million
dollars in back pay an interest after
Department of Labor audit found that
State Street was systematically paying
female employees less than their male
counterparts and black executives less
than similar similarly situated white
executives my colleague from Illinois
highlighted some troubling connections
between Morgan Stanley and Puerto Rico's
illegal debt load 2018 goldman sachs
face began facing lawsuits from DOJ the
Fed foreign governments
in relation to funding bribes and
kickbacks to foreign officials relating
to raising funds for Malaysia's
sovereign wealth fund Tim you Timothy
Lightner the Goldman Southeast Asia
executive pled guilty to various charges
and forfeited 43 million and just last
month March of 2019 Citibank fined 425
million dollars for violating the Fair
Housing Act for failing to offer
benefits to all eligible customers
namely on the basis of race national
origin and sex and so I'm concerned here
about the potentiality of fines related
to misconduct just being incorporated as
the cost of doing business and mr.
Corbitt is a cost-benefit analysis that
weighs the cost of government fines
versus the potential financial upside of
potentially breaking a law does that
factor into controversial
decision-making around misconduct and at
your bank absolutely not okay in my
district I represent Rikers Island
I represent kids that go to jail for
jumping a turnstile because they can't
afford a MetroCard do you think that
more folks should have gone to jail for
the for their role in a financial crisis
that led to 7.8 million foreclosures in
the ten years between 2007 and 2016 mr.
Dimon I don't think people should go to
jail for jumping in the subway and we
put too many people into jail and I
think if people broke the law they
shouldn't go to jail mm-hmm okay and do
you think that the failure to hold more
people accountable for the 2008 crisis
as a failure over failure of our legal
system
[Music]
look you have to talk to a lot of legal
experts about why more people didn't
whether they deserve to they broke the
law
what's intent what's not intent but you
have to talk about legal experts about
that
on that note mr. diamond I do want to
commend you for your decision and
Chase's decision to pull out of
financing for private prisons and I
think that that has led to some changes
particularly with Wells Fargo as well
and in in making sure that we begin to
divest from some of the troubling things
that we're seeing particularly when it
comes to the caging of children at our
border I have one last question with
respect to that's more future looking
recently the Federal Reserve Board
decided not to activate the
counter-cyclical capital buffer this
year but banks are very profitable
making a record 237 billion in profits
last year mr. Corbett is this not the
best time for banks is it is this not
the best time for the Fed to build more
capital so that they can be in a better
position to weather a future downturn as
I stated earlier today by the feds own
measurement they're measuring 23 or 24
different types of capital what we've
said is we're welcome to a holistic
approach of which the counter-cyclical
buffer is one but rather than pick
individual let's look holistically at
what the right solution is the gentleman
from New York mr. Zeldin is recognized